(unclear)
It has about 10 to 12 centimetres of slack, sometimes 15 centimetres, and we need that slack for the accelerated flight.
When we accelerate, the wing is tilted forward and down, with the trailing edge raised slightly higher at the back.
And when we then look straight up — we always look up — our brake is curving back behind us.
It makes a proper arc, and that has to be that way, right?
So when we're in accelerated flight, the brake is tensioned at the rear.
And we must not pull the brake at all in accelerated flight,
because if we now additionally pull the brake on top of that,
at that moment it briefly generates more lift,
and the wing can have a frontal collapse.
Briefly — you can't even really call it a clap — but in any case, the collapse risk
is significantly increased, and that's the reason you don't steer at all
in accelerated flight.
So, we can't do that anymore,
steering with the brakes.
Now, now.
Now,
up to now you've held the brake like this,
uh, in your hand,
and the problem with that, especially during thermal flying,
is that you often have to work the brakes pretty deep down there.
Or in strong thermals you have to brake harder occasionally.
Meaning the working range, over a longer time period,
becomes very, very tiring.
And that's why many pilots go and shorten that brake travel, so to speak,
by holding the brake differently.
There's the so-called French grip.
The French often do this — not all of them,
but many — they start with the brake handle
and then hold this small brake line
between — they hold this brake line between index finger and thumb.
Through that you get a very good feel.
You've also shortened the brake a bit,
and you saw that he wasn't able to deploy the reserve.
So it really could be down to the fact
that you can't get out of the brake handle anymore.
So, if you want to do this,
then you really can do it,
by simply keeping the thumb on the outside.
And that way you come out of this loop faster.
The Hungarians — there's the Hungarian grip,
the Hungarians then said, hang on,
that's already too risky for us.
We still want to keep the brake line between index finger and thumb.
And that's why the Hungarians went over to —
they just hold the brake up high like this.
That way you can of course let go at any time and grab the reserve.
But the risk is also greater
that we might really lose the line by accident.
Then you need a moment again
to grab it.
From that point of view, for me it's not really a great option.
I personally don't choose it.
What we do instead is shorten the brake really aggressively.
So we take out those 10 to 12 centimetres of slack,
by keeping the brake quite normally on the strap in the hand.
And then making a so-called wrap outward.
Look — I'm rotating it outward.
And now I lead this brake line past the heel of my hand here.
And I can keep it loosely between index finger and thumb in my hand.
Have a very good feel for the wing.
And now have a very short steering travel.
Meaning I now only work in here.
And because of that, it's far less tiring.
I have a shorter travel, feel the wing better,
less tiring, and the advantage is that you can take out the wrap at any time again.
Or, if I need a wrap,
I just put in even more.
Stall, where I feel the wing, two wraps.
Okay, so a really big advantage.
(unclear)